okay so now let's talk about something
more tangible in Venezuela when Juan
guava first entered the conversation as
interim president despite Nicolas Maduro
claiming that he was legitimately
re-elected in Venezuela we asked what's
going to happen next who's going to
prevail here and as I said at the time
it's really going to be influenced by
the military because in these it's very
common historically that when you have
these authoritarian types like Nicolas
Maduro that they have the support of the
military at least for some period of
time and when there is an attempt to
actually have some kind of real
democracy or fair elections or whatever
other method of accountability is tried
to to be put in place it will often come
down to the military if the military
stays behind Maduro it's likely Maduro
will retain control if the military
starts to split or abandon Maduro it
becomes more likely that guai though
will prevail as interim president and
that hopefully new elections will be
held we now have some high-profile
military defections to tell you about
the first is General Francisco Esteban
yáñez Rodriguez who is disavowing what
he calls the dictatorial authority of
Nicolas Maduro and is recognizing Juan Y
though as the interim president he put
out a video which were showing to our TV
and YouTube audience in military uniform
he's identified as the director of
strategic planning in the high command
of the Venezuelan Air Force that matches
how he's identified on the Air Force
website so that all checks out and this
is the highest ranking military
defection so far there have been some
lower ranking defections as well which
maybe we'll talk about later in the week
the general says that the military
should stop defending Maduro that if
they're afraid of internal threats from
the military then they should simply
stay at home the general also says that
Maduro has airplanes ready to go to flee
if it gets to that point and of course
the general hopes that it does and this
is absolutely huge because the way that
these authoritarian autocrats stay
power especially in Latin American
history and as many of you know I'm from
Argentina we've had dictatorships in
Argentina and the most recent one ending
right around the time that I was born
these individuals these authoritarian
autocrats retain control when they have
the support of the military once you
don't things start to crumble now is
there precedent for authoritarian
dictators to leave what we would call
somewhat peacefully there are so the
Shah of Iran left in 1979 and died in
exile in Egypt now it didn't work out
super well because then the Islamic
Republic was declared but at least the
Shah did leave without starting but by
definition a a sort of bloody war and
and so it is with precedent
maybe Nicolas Maduro is being pushed
closer and closer to that in Ethiopia
Miriam fled the country when it was
clear he wasn't going to win was
promised asylum by Robert Mugabe in
Zimbabwe Idi Amin went to Saudi Arabia
until his death so there are examples of
this now in Iran again what's
particularly depressing is that the
people mostly did want democracy the way
that I believe the Venezuelan people
also want democracy but the Islamic
Republic came out on top and that's a
reality so that's when it circles back
to the geopolitics well Trump wants this
and McCrone is on this side and the
Argentinian president is on that side
let's first evaluate whether Maduro
deserves our support then let's figure
out are we electing people in the US
that are going to intervene in ways we
don't want and deal with that and then
of course we have to be aware of the
reality that just because you remove
someone who shouldn't be there or
someone who shouldn't be there is pushed
out by the Pott by the public that
doesn't guarantee that you're going to
get a replacement that you like and Iran
is a really really good example of that
where might Maduro go
some say Bolivia although I read one
interesting piece that says it's not
going to be Bolivia Nicaragua has been
mentioned Cuba has been mentioned
although that's almost more complicated
for Cuba which does seem to want to
continue to improve relations with the
United States the more likely Maduro is
to have an idea of where he could go and
never face consequences the more likely
it is that he might leave power
peacefully and that is of course what we
should all be hoping for for the sake of
the Venezuelan people let me know where
you are on this issue I know you will
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show we'll be
back right after this today's program is
sponsored in part by movement
Valentine's Day is coming up movement
knows exactly what to get for that
special someone
get the curated Valentine's Day gift
boxes complete with perfectly matched
watches and bracelets or a watch and
strap movement introduce jewelry to
their collections not long ago this one
is a no-brainer
one and done I hate shopping for gifts
for people I also hate giving cliche
gifts like chocolate or flowers give a
gift that someone actually wants give
something like a watch that makes an
effortless statement maintaining that
clean minimal design and high quality
that we've come to know and love from
movement the prices start at just 95
bucks interchangeable straps for tons of
occasions I have a movement watch with
all sorts of different straps that I
swap out depending on what I'm doing get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to M V M t.com
slash Pakman CY movement keeps growing
check out their expanding collection at
M VMT comm /p a que ma n join the
movement